yeah I need I need my writers I need
them real bad
yeah I got no show without my Riders
this is a show that is built on strong
writing a strong writing is essential to
the show it's essential to any show
where the host myself is at best a c
plus performer
the jokes
live next weekend but then this week
they're like uh all right you know as
you know the writers strike might happen
that's right so if a workout is like two
three months and they're like yeah well
we'll know Monday if it's happening or
not might not happen like please take
care of them you know they got to get a
fair deal so uh yeah I'll do whatever I
can to support them and hopefully there
is no strike and they can figure out a
deal
no one look no one is entitled to a job
in show business but for those people
who have a job in Show Business they are
entitled to Fair compensation uh they
are entitled to make a living I think
it's a very reasonable demand that is
being set up uh by The Guild and I
support those demands